21 juin 2021 cette date est synonyme de
retour à la vie normale pour le royaume
uni mais c'est sans compter sur le
variant un 10 ans qui s'invite un peu
plus dans le quotidien des britanniques
boris johnson à d'ailleurs d'ores et
déjà prévenu ce mutant pourrait venir
perturber le bon déroulement du
déconfinement dans le pays
nous pensons que ce variant est plus
contagieux que le précédent en d'autres
termes il se transmet plus facilement
d'une personne à l'autre et nous ne
savons pas à quel point
s'il n'est que marginalement plus
transmissible nous pourrons continuer
plus ou moins comme prévu mais si le
variant entre du transmissibles nous
serons probablement confrontés à des
choix difficiles
je dois être honnête avec vous sur le
fait que ce nouveau variant pourrait
perturber sérieusement nos progrès pts
et rendre plus difficile le passage à la
quatrième étape prévue en juin
une pièce je dois souligner que nous
ferons tout ce qui sera nécessaire pour
assurer la sécurité de la population qui
excelle des mesures pour tenter
d'enrayer la propagation du variant b 1
617 deux ont déjà été mises en oeuvre
outre-manche par exemple l'intervalle
entre l'injection des deux doses de
vaccin a été réduit à huit semaines pour
les plus de 50 ans et les personnes
vulnérables alors qu'il peut aller
jusqu'à trois mois actuellement
la vaccination pourrait aussi être
élargi aux plus jeunes car il ya urgence
de 520 nouveaux cas la semaine dernière
le variant indien représente au moment
où l'on parle 1313 cas beaucoup se
concentrent dans le nord ouest du
territoire
le royaume uni est le deuxième pays le
plus affecté par ce variant qui a été
détecté dans 44 pays en dehors de l'inde
selon les données de l'om s
l'organisation mondiale de la santé l'a
d'ailleurs
ajouté à sa liste de variants considérés
comme préoccupants en cause sa
contagiosité plus élevée et sa
potentielle résistance aux vaccins comme
l'a précisé la scientifique en chef de
l' oms l afp le variant b 1 617
présentent des mutations qui augmente
les transmissions et qui peuvent aussi
potentiellement le rendre résistant aux
anticorps qui se sont développés grâce à
la vaccination ou à une contamination
naturel mais face à la confusion autour
de ce mutant la scientifique en chef de
l' oms a précisé que ce variant ne peut
être tenu pour seul responsable de
l'explosion de l'épidémie en inde
le représentant de l'instance onusienne
dans le pays a d'ailleurs aussi appelé à
la retenue
quant au discours sur ce variant de son
côté public al finland le service public
de santé de l'angleterre souligne on ne
sait pas si et dans quelle mesure il
peut réduire l'efficacité des vaccins
toujours est il que certains pays
prennent leurs précautions ainsi si
l'allemagne a replacé le royaume uni
dans sa liste des zones à risque en
france 24 cas impliquant le variant
indiens ont été détectés sur le
territoire la majorité de ces cas est
lié à des retour d'un séjour en inde
précis santé publique france